so we were searching for weight shops on
Washington Boulevard well we got my
google search history all loaded up and
my father is gonna take a look you've
been working on a lot of stuff for
school so should be a lot of stuff about
that right
she's so we're also everything she does
is a word team to do I'll start from the
top
lay sex no no this least six you are not
going to Burning Man I don't even know
why you're looking at it oh my god
under Oh Janos I add Rajan as' little
ways baby mama how much money Floyd
Mayweather made at the fight it was a
lot does Kim really love Kanye you are
nosy the computer cannot tell you it
can't really love hi hey what's this one
first aid kit first aid kit oh I don't
need that why did you need a first aid
kit no this is actually more exciting
for myself I love to like go back and
see what I relive relive my life here
Antonio Banderas us Mexicans need to
represent in the media he's not I should
go to you instead of Google so we were
searching for weight shops on Washington
Boulevard how to cook pasta you boil
water where are you you have a Google
where you were I think I got teased
Nicki Minaj anaconda stripping the music
video is just booties everywhere you're
still looking up spongebob things oh my
god that it was a gift from who who gave
it to you we went from tinder and our
own bubble it's an app it's a dating app
called yeah
a lot better and how about was it bad
hygiene habits what
what would you be googling bad hygiene
habits so you can do them so you can do
know so I can see if my habits matched
up to that then I know I have a problem
how many steps does it take to walk to
Mexico from here right here from LA from
LA this is amazing I am blown away by
this stuff here now what's the seven
types of boys you might want to meet in
may get out of it wait when does my
inhale come and who's my inmate get out
of many Central Jail yeah okay what was
that wait what was that and then you
have here how to high email addresses
what's this Adam but how to hide email
addresses oh I really don't remember do
you know somebody in jail okay
[Laughter]
although uh caught you red-handed
sponsoring sponsoring somebody wait like
yeah sure
they art pulled it member and I sent out
the newsletter aha
I needed to figure out how to make it
anonymous that's cool uh-huh sure Adam
yeah yeah yeah you just put in the BCC
definitely I learned that she's so well
but she's my daughter so where are we I
think I need to do this more often I
think you don't to be honest
thanks for letting me with the kids your
email how are your my search history but
yeah I'm you do eat someone else yeah
delete your histories ha ha ha
especially for things you don't want
anyone to see don't worry I did that and
everything was cool
there's did of course we do you think as
always sir
[Music]
[Music]